[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to the iron
lords podcast first look for biomutant
my name is pete also known as naldo here
to give you a little bit of a little
insight and a little
little tidbit of invisibility of what
biomutant looks like
and how fantastic this game is so
this game has been published by thq
nordic
and we first encounter ourselves kind of
learning the ins and outs of the
fighting
and learning how to operate as this
creature
now this game is a pretty much
it's an open world combat game
i would consider it a more
post-apocalyptic
type game because a lot of the world has
been destroyed
and there's these creatures that are
essentially sucking the life force
out of the world and you have been sent
and
you are the the
son or daughter of a
um of them of this amazing kung fu
master
and you're sent out uh to to go and just
dispatch these creatures now the
creatures themselves
uh i have been working towards and i
played
for for a very long time trying to push
myself
to get closer and closer to these
creatures to be able to get
you know to to fight them and i still
haven't even been able to do that after
about seven or eight hours of of play
time
so this game is got a lot of depth to it
a lot of side missions a lot of side
quests
so let's just take a step back and kind
of explain
you are this what some people call like
almost like a rodent
uh and you have a huge knowledge of you
know
fighting uh with melee and also with
shooting of weapons uh and you get
you know guns and swords and daggers and
you build everything on your own
so everything is super unique and
throughout the whole entire world these
objects are all over there so that you
can end up
figuring out how how to fight and defend
yourself and also these towns from
everything
now the hardest part about this game is
the camera angles uh it took me a little
bit of a while to kind of figure out how
to deal with the cameras but after i
figured that out
it really wasn't that bad the uh the
environments are
are amazing uh they're very very large
they're beautifully you know they're
beautifully colored uh
the artist's work is the best part of
this whole entire thing
uh the storyline it seems like it's very
uh
thought like you're really thought out
really well done
some of the characters the way that they
communicate not the best
but uh i think that you still get the
point across and you understand it
which is really really a good thing now
the the game itself it takes a little
bit to kind of get going but once it
starts gets going
you want to keep going so after you know
i started playing after like the first
three hours or so i was kind of like
all right are we doing something and
then the next thing it was like boom
another big thing happened and you
started you know the quest to
essentially
go after the first creature so it really
really
took a little bit to get into but it
really worked out well
now as for the the combat the combat is
quick and i loved it and it really
really was enjoyable
so if you like quick combat and you
really really enjoy
liking and seeing how things work out
fluidly
then you can really go take a look at
that uh there's mechs in there
uh i'm telling you there's there's a lot
of things that you don't expect but i
will tell you
it is very very interesting oh and by
the way you have telekinetic abilities
because you know
as a little rodent from a post
apocalyptic world
that uses kung fu things you gotta make
sure you have that so uh thanks again
everybody for taking a look at this
first look video
uh and i will talk to you all soon uh
make sure you go and check out the iron
lords podcast
on on sundays uh and myself
now though i'm you know on twitch on
monday on
monday to friday every morning and night
uh
and thank you very much for uh for
checking out this video and see you all
soon
the colors match each other oh
i try again let's try that again
there you go there
you go
yeah i figured i didn't realize that at
the time
we got it now
uh it's professor x
perfectly countering an enemy will stun
them
the wheeled one is outnumbered you'd
better help him out
oh
the wheeled one
it's like the currency no
i left things in there
damn it
he wants to thank you for taking his
side against the scavengers
he sounds familiar you just can't figure
out
why he presents himself as
out of date he knows he's way overdue
but he hasn't given up
he doesn't seem surprised that you don't
recognize him you were just a child back
then
the night everything changed
there have been rumors of a one-eyed
ronin seen outside the great wall
and he's happy to see it's true
the legend of the one-eyed child that
grew up as an
outcast is old
the child could have been anyone but the
evil it had fled had left a mark a
facial scar
to remember the past
there's no doubt you're the child and
that what looper lupin
did to your village your mumma and popsy
was the beginning of the end
he says it has taken you a long time to
bring the past back up to the present
to find your way back but he's grateful
you have
it was after the attack all the unity
fell apart
your mum's disciples divided and formed
tribes as a reaction to the blight
that had fallen upon the land
had it not been for the tree of life no
one would have survived
he hopes you at least remember the tree
let's hope we probably don't but we hope
oh
are you kidding me right now
[Music]
asks if you were tired as it's a bit of
a hike here from the village
he wonders if your mumma knows you are
here
you're such a good child so you probably
did
even the young forget
he understands why you came all the way
out here to see
them the potato people
[Music]
the potato people or nano are a
wonder somehow interlinked with this
little tree here
fueling
[Music]
an excellent source of key
the nano prefer to hide in glitter grass
he says you should get over there and
ruffle it see if you can make one
come out of hiding oh my god
that was terrible
you found one what be proud they don't
come out for everyone
the nano's key energy is just what the
pencil
needs to complete its cycle and grow
into a tree of life
only time will tell at least his
intention is to dedicate his life to it
he has the feeling the fate of the world
depends on it
you need to support the tree for a long
time to come
the only way it'll grow tall is with the
burst of
key released from the nano as they
become one
with the tree
you will need a net my god and he wants
you to use his
but asks you to be gentle the nano are
sensitive beings
an embodiment of key the primal energy
this guy
[Music]
you handle that net like you've never
done anything else
he's impressed
but today your focus is getting this one
to become one with the tree
[Music]
that was hilarious
[Music]
you have no reason to doubt
from this day on he'll make nurturing
the pencil
into a tree of life a life goal
not only for our village's sake but for
all of us
everyone one day
the land won't be as peaceful not even
your mumma
will be able to protect us the sky
he says you better hurry back to the
village before your mumma comes looking
for you
you did good here today
[Music]
oh my god on her mind who needs rest
after the raid last night on the looping
camp with her disciples
wonders if they let the predator family
live or not
oh my god he lost you there for a while
but no memory is alone it's part of a
trail you can follow
he says he remembers every single day he
devoted to growing the tree of life
but now he's afraid it might be in vain
the tree started to die when the end of
days began
and it wasn't long after that that the
one the genetic evolution this guy
doesn't sound like elvis
it's the same guy an all corporation
inflicted on the land set the world
eaters dna into overdrive
his friend gizmo is working on a mechdon
and needs help defeating the jumbo puff
at the end
of the west route
whiz is still repairing his octopod to
confront the merc puff that dwells deep
down under the surface at the end of the
northwest route
noco has tamed the majority and is
preparing to take on the hoof puff at
the end of the east route
finally those are each of the zones
a machine able to ride the waves of the
surf all the way out to the porchy puff
at the end of the route to the southeast
my young out of date says his friends
are gearing up to stop the world eaters
there's one at the end of each route
the road ahead won't be easy but he's
counting on yours so
you're supposed to go defeat these
creatures
if the tree isn't saved
regardless you'll meet again once you've
played your part in the tribe war and
the situation with the world eaters
oh we got the net
all great feet of the world
i think it's cool that the shadow you
see the shadows
like are the uh are the uh
animals he's talking about
note how there's a ginormous open area
up here
that they didn't talk about
now bye
you just pried the door open and now
that dude is unprotected
like are you kidding me and the rope
looks strong enough to climb
what is the items i left you're still
here
no they're not
so i guess our objective is to go do one
of these so i guess we'll take on this
one on the right first
know that the tree of life is dying its
days are numbered
there's a lot of cutscenes can't endure
the environmental change
under salt from the world eaters
oh that's a viable cutscene
40k
the other one's going down
oh that seems fun
we're gonna go towards the chest no
trouble loses chests
all right good sprint
a signpost maps it out for the
cartographically
challenged oh let's see
just peed on it
couldn't see any of what
i put it on i thought i saw i thought
you guys saw that
i'm sorry i could've swore i hit the
button for you guys to see that
my deepest apologies
i will make sure that i am more
in tune with it and i will double check
it before i
run the raids
what the hell
what is that thing
that must be the world eater that chewed
off out of dates leg
you'll need a hat trick to bring that
down
holy
look a survivor that deceased
he's heard the stories about the terror
inflicted by the world eaters to other
enclaves
but never expected one to come all the
way here
your imbalance is two halves
that completes the wholeness of those
two
or a score which affects dialogue
if this continues even if the tree of
life survives the attack
he doesn't know what your connection is
to this place but something
tells him you've stayed true to your
heart
directing with captives and sunshines
will award you sight points
that you can use to unlock side power as
powers can only be unlocked once you
have
reached the required a dark or a light
inner any woman he needs help
and says it's by your actions you'll be
judged
i say yes he's grateful for that
you still seem to have a spark of light
in you
that's a spark of light in you
what's there to like about light it
hurts
not as much as it hurts to look at you
always making this
oh you're always trying to pretend it's
not
you can't disappoint you just happened
to unlock those mutations
there's out of date again he must have
missed something important
tribe is likely to be a good match as
they act on the understanding of the
greater good
and have a code of honor
regardless of who you choose it won't be
easy as the conflict between the tribes
is worse than ever
teetering on the brink of war
the myriad's conviction to stop the
world eaters began when the leviathans
rose from the depths of the surf
siding with the myriad's movement for
wholeness in a fragmented world might
seem like the logical thing to do
but is it the right thing one thing's
certain though
destiny arrives all the same
the japanese tribe only ever had one
conviction
to bring balance to the world by wiping
out the weak
they believe a cleansing is necessary to
restore the world
and want to let the world eaters bring
down the tree of life
but siding with chutney isn't
necessarily a bad thing
fate will find a way
he believes the tribe sifus myriad
especially
will listen to you and expect you to pay
at least
one of them a visit and play your part
out of date we'll be waiting for you
beneath the tree of life if you lose
track of what you need to do
great
apparently we have side mutations now we
have to
we have a blink to use blink press down
the input you have bounce
the ability to we'll celebrate
you to a location and create a shockwave
that's pretty nice this will
cause us to bounce around
blink yes unlock this ability
displaying press down on the input that
you're bound to the ability it will
teleport you
in the direction you are moving create a
shockwave
this ability press the button down it's
bound to while pl pressing the
right left trigger
hey
another fork in the road it's either the
tunnel or the motor bridge would it
well i'm be sure we gotta go to the
right so
it's unusual that natural tunnels like
this still exist
most of them got flooded
you got to admit the environments are
pretty damn sweet looking
oh these are like level five guys
oh
interesting i don't know why i could
only attack those guys not the other
guys
this area was beautiful before the tribe
war began
look at it now it's a war zone
yes we have to go this way
that's the myriad tribe's fortress will
they be friends
or foe you should head up there that way
you'll know
it's a beaten path to that door if you
go there you'd better make an entrance
oh god you guys are killed they're at
war
he let you in but thinks you should be
patient when it comes
to the seafood
[Music]
we attack the wrong people
of the greater good and a code of honor
they believe
uniting the tribes is the only way to
restore the peace
that's what i would do is convince the
defeating
the world eaters and saving the tree of
life is the only way to make the world a
better place
he welcomes you to the myriad fort and
introduces
himself as the tribe's sifu well let's
see if you can watch it now
show up the news of a vigilante ronin on
crusade
crossing the great wall through the
cracking bunker 101 has preceded you
against the scavengers in bunker 101
it seems you believe in helping your
next and that's something you have in
common
there's something about your spirit that
sparks memories of you as a kiddling he
can still
sense your kind-hearted i applied i
tried running it i
i don't like it one memory can make
another come to life
he hasn't thought about your mumma for
ages even though she taught him a lot
he was one of the original wong fu
disciples
originally it consisted of unarmed
combat and the six weapons
the boomerang the shuriken the bow the
staff
the nanchok and the hook and chain
myriad wants unity between the tribes
their goal is understanding of the
greater good
and establishing a code of honor if you
believe there's some good in everyone
there's still hope for tomorrow
you'll unite the tribes and defeat the
world eaters to save the tree of life
warnings is the game's end game goal to
save the tree of life
choosing destiny to defeat rival stifuz
is limited
to unite or subdue
you understand that there's no harm in
doing good to others
the sifu was waiting for something to
tip the balance in their favor
and with you by their side he's
confident you can
unite the other tribes the one you
should coerce
first is the jagne
their tribe have run out of options and
found themselves backed into a corner
even those who desire peace have been
forced to prepare for war
he wants you to focus these are the new
rival outposts your tribe needs to take
control of
he says you'll regret not being on their
side
the only way you'll learn their secrets
and the tribe weapon now is if you
defeat him
and that will never happen
you both have gentle minds so they want
to wage a gentle
war a war that bonds as much as it
breaks
tells you not to be afraid your fate
cannot be taken from you
claim the rival outposts and earn the
right to wield the tribe weapon
once you've dealt with the rivals
outposts
you'll challenge their sifu to unite
their tribe
with yours and let your kin share land
again
seeing you brings back his memories of
the old
okay he remembers your kind and
unselfish soul and conservatives
then go after the scene to do good to
get the weapon anyway
the memories you make with your family
are strong
and can sometimes come to life passing
the old village on your way to the first
rival outpost might help
you have things to do places wishes you
goodbye
right
the tree's going to bleed death from its
roots if you keep taking
has plenty to do
so
all ready
hard as nails
waiting for one more
gotta get one more upgrade point
we will take fall damage
you gotta admit though this game is
pretty beautiful to look at
they did a really good job with the
environment
i don't know how i feel about the story
yet though combat's okay
but it is very similar to
what uh what it normally is
the green fur was my choice so
mama
slap
wow
well there are mutations of whatever
life
was here
better beware that's a month up ahead
they were hit hard by evolution
the wonky ones especially deformed and
unfurred
oh
now that's a flesh
um
huh
what you been
like these like they these runes
would be fantastic if they had runes
similar to the way that they had uh
other games
that would be cool
time is lost on this place but it evokes
a tingling sensation
there's something special about it
drawing you closer
look look how they do with the waypoints
you pees on them let's see
and sometimes feelings change it's not
about who you were
it's about who you become this story is
far from
over echoes of a long lost
past like whispers in the wind
here's someone who takes each day as it
comes
he wonders where you've been he hopes
you've been out at the lake
practicing your swimming technique
oh my god
learning to swim can be scary when you
don't know what you're doing
but fortunately he's here to give you a
helping hand
he thinks you should really know how to
swim by now
and he'll be honored
the game is about your creature that's
trying to save the world that's being
essentially destroyed
but it's like
it's really really like some of these
characters are very very weird
[Music]
he says that wasn't too bad was it
oh
it seems you forgot something but it's
it's very weird
you promised you'd train with her before
the sun goes down
it's time to go
the dedication to training is important
you can't rely solely on the fact that
you should know she'll see you at the
village square
she says that's good
here's another familiar face with his
mind
you should
sometimes he's an expert but sometimes
he just does what's fine
he can work wonders with almost anything
and asks if you know how to
up cycle
he'd love to teach you to upcycle and
the scrap you
oh
meaning making them stronger represent
your own weapons
base
um
here sir
crush one-handed slash two-handed slash
[Music]
stand
[Music]
attack speed you want
a little on the faster side
and grind
[Music]
to continue crafting your weapon
selector
the handle
banana
[Music]
bad
pipe wrench
oak
interesting
you did well but he can't help but
wonder why you decided to craft a weapon
it looks like she's starting to lose her
patience oh no
you know she doesn't like waiting for
you she wants to see you on the village
then you've got a good excuse she wants
you to grow up and start
thinking for yourself you really need to
find yourself before she's gone
that's
so are we able to oh we can't do
anything else here
they look determined better watch out
he asks you to stop right there and
wonders where you think you're going
that makes you wonder why you were here
looking for it
he wants to know who you think you are
you'll have to face pain no one wants
you to get hurt
i do not like the camera angles
[Music]
oh
she asks if you're heard what happened
she's there for all disciples that's her
commitment
a sifu and when she needs them they're
there for her and each other
the most important thing is that you're
okay
it's time to focus on your training now
next battlefield is ready for everybody
here's someone close to heart doing what
he does best
as soon as your father he asks if you
could help him
too before you leave for training
he wishes that was true for your mum too
but guiding the village into the future
and teaching wong fu to her disciples
seems more important for every day
he suggests you get going and find him
gadgets and ideas for how you can
upcycle some old fabrics old fabrics
game is a great concept i i'm hoping
that the
story
he's all for renewal and has even
considered making the trip out into the
wilds to look for a bio-nucleus pool
and refresh his dna he says it's about
time you learned how
and offers to teach you starting with
the scrap you found
crafting here now
armor increasing armor
that's pretty cool
the style might be too edgy for his
taste
but look sharp on
he's looking forward to seeing what
you'll make next it seems you have a
talent for this
great i gotta train i'm gonna get my
butt kicked
oops you're as ready as you claim to be
she says she is eager to get started you
don't have much time left before the sun
goes down
[Music]
hahaha
muma says you did well today she's so
proud of you
very thanks you for being such a good
student
been working on a present for you with
the help of gizmo and whiz
you should go see him and find out what
he
catchy your mumma says she's never seen
an apparatus as green as this little
thing
it's wonderful a piece of scraptronics
like this has
built-in old world tech that makes it a
potent communication device
it's called an automaton and it's
hardwired to your dna
it'll follow wherever you go and see
whatever you see
you're lucky to have such a fine helper
with you
your mumma says you look tired no wonder
it's been a long day says a good rest
rest and you'll find strength for
tomorrow
nothing could stop
your mumma urges you to blaze a trail
a burnt kiddling will learn to dread
fire
that's just adding fuel to the flames
give it a last burst and you'll make it
something will fall in the way and
she'll have to initiate combat on her
own
this time there's no escape she can hear
him coming
whatever happens you need to know she
loves you
and everything she's done has been to
protect you
your pop here it comes the past coming
to haunt the present
you must go through fire and water to
make it out of here
he just eated me halfway across the
world your luma says you can make it if
you believe in it
where she goes you go blood is thicker
than water
you're in deep surf don't make waves
the surf goes where it wants to go it'll
take you to the shore as long as you go
with the flow
[Music]
hmm
you guys see the actions popping up
right
death is not to be feared by one who has
lived life with a pure heart
a part of her will live on in you
didn't even die in combat she died
drowning for more
nothing is going to stand in its way now
wow
if a sacrifice is made for someone else
it's not lost
but passed on to the next life must go
on
real sacrifice comes from love and
necessity
when all other options are exhausting
the ultimate test of consciousness is
the willingness to give up
anything to save what you truly care
about
what you do for yourself dies with you
what you do for your kin remains and
makes you
immortal in their memory
wow
as the moment fades and is lost the only
thing that remains is
loneliness it doesn't mean you'll forget
your past
it simply means you need to move on
i also mean we can craft stuff now
craft stuff now
time to
get crafty
don't
[Music]
you look great
uh okay learned that one
the tribe's caught a fluffy hulk better
watch out it's no pet
they couldn't keep it down fluff hulk's
on the loose
lightning
well-placed
oh
that tingled
i did not expect him to whack for that
much whew
they couldn't keep it down fluff hulk's
on the loose
this is clearly one of those bosses you
keep arranged
hello
they've received musa ronin had
strengthened their ranks and were
looking forward to meeting you
a group of myriad crusaders already
headed out to jagne's mercado's outpost
and are waiting for you there ned you
had to
buy you you should hurry there and help
them best the outpost
the myriad tribe is prepared to fight to
the death for souls that will be forever
lost if not saved
open our chances luck
dude that's the thing like i don't know
oh
[Music]
weird
uh
i will take it
look an emergency box from the old days
when you needed to pack a punch to
survive
wow bet that nut makes a tight fit what
a tool
that's crazy
for the new weapon type
interesting
the top of the world is set
oh well you need to have it equipped
tunnels like this still carry echoes
from the past
can you hear it
oh he's one of those bio creatures
great
that's
um
a smartphone
[Music]
um
sharp steel
i think we got it
uh more informational thing i was very
confused about what that was
new stack was the automated trial notice
board
filled with the leftovers of used to be
once
you're getting close to one of those old
toxinol
brick towns pay attention
the toxinol corporation made this place
and then just threw it away when well
small ones places like this there must
be a track
somewhere in this
[Music]
um
it's kind of interesting that now we
have the ability you look
ready how the hell do you see out of
anything
i think we have medical supplies
oh rubber handle
crafted for craftable weapon that's nice
i don't know does that mean we go this
way or does that mean we go that way
that way is a side quest
uh let's go experience let's go this way
so we can experience
side quests and see how it is see what
it's about see what they're thinking and
all that
stuff be careful
this corner of the world is uh super
blue one
three old gadgets
no such luck
face mask question is
is it better than the one we have
a level needed five
all right so we did this already
make sure we pee on it
let's see
this one we were in already correct no
i will say these are nice for supplies
and these frame rates oh my god
game's beautiful they gotta figure out
where their memory leak is
oh a hat
looks like the frey sparkers knobs need
to be in sync if you want to get the
hardware working
just a few moves left make them count
it's a fry sparkle mindset
it's not exactly what you wanted but you
got it right away
a story has got to keep moving forward
those pants man nice looking pants
eastman
we are looting it right
fits you well
so a flush stool seems like the
tighteners on the piping need to be
unturned correctly to drain the flush
stool
just a few moves left make them count
there we go
flush stool that's the kind of trouble
you really want to wash away
yo angry what's up dude it might take a
little more than one
all right i'm going back up um
that building
this building
make sure we're doing all these things
right
sushi shop these are all closed
garbage
take whatever we can get our hands on
um
i feel like i'm missing something here
missing something in these towns it's a
game of life
yours and everyone else's
that's cool looks valuable
oh that's gold
oh
i was just missing an old world gadget
you found the track
amazing it wasn't destroyed so much of
this place was just
discarded lucky the track somehow made
it
no it was never nice it was new
once but that's not nearly the same
thing
just being new never lasts
the tracks moved on from bricktown
and you should too
but we are missing
we're missing one thing from here
same over here a pie
we're here
now over here the tribes need
someone to unite them in here
what's the next building over
the next building over
let's see
i don't know
i don't know where this last old piece
was
um
all right i guess this is our last place
we can check
this guy's like the fonz he just punches
stuff and stuff comes out of it
oh that i hope that was the thing but
it's not
all right
now
so
here
inventory
your bits
ranged parts for melee parts
he's got his tools
he did level up but where are we gonna
put this now
uh luck agility
looks good put into luck hopefully some
luck we will get some better gear
dual melee we don't have anything for
ranged guns
dual wield guns
all the stuff is pretty
self-explanatory so
so much uh all right
all right i guess we can is there a
fast travel point
or no
who's this
i guess we go to the war party
oh
i couldn't see
so it seems like right before any big
event happens
you found the whereabouts the deepest
darkest forest in the land sometimes
hard to see
wow these guys are hard
who could stand against that
so
i gotta remember jump when he does that
good feet
um
slip on by
give a key a shot
here what are we gonna get for gear a
screw
[Music]
a bullseye
done mod that's pretty cool
that was not what i was expecting
that's the only way to get over to the
other side is to go down through the
sewers again like we did before
sort of seems like
i wish i knew this that last place was i
was missing
never you need to get the pegs to get
the clothes soaker rolling
just a few moves left make them count
there we go last one
we got it
[Music]
a rifle
the day is here
all right i swear where's the exit here
this
uh
or we gotta go down through
that's how we got there
you went this way
i'm missing something
wouldn't be surprised if we are missing
something
after the next stream raiders i'm gonna
take a five minute break
what's the other ability
the x ray trigger
um
wow
i'm not
getting dimmer by the minute
oh the big guy jeez
that's not cool
that's a resource totem a monument left
behind by those that picked scrap
trying to keep the area clean hmm
especially with your open together
materials for
crafting weapons nice
some barkwood scrap for you
that's pretty cool
that's a jackman tribe outpost
what's this
like this looks abnormal not shouldn't
be here
you find a green leaf plant jump through
the loop to collect leaves you can use
that to buy things later green is the
monument currency
okay
railroad system
is that that blue puff was that like
in the distance or was that like here
you can make so many amazing things out
of old scrap
all right
love it when you get stuff like that
what is that
you found a bio-contaminated container
use the bio
blobs and use these to unlock mutations
in the menus or change your appearance
at the bio pools
disgusting biohazard just gross
fantastic
i wonder if the levels are the way that
they do the leveling system
i wish it was an mmo rpg it would be
amazing
i just can't play game solo i usually
don't end up playing game solo but this
is one of those ones that i needed
to be able to take breaks when i could
so
uh give me two seconds i'll be right
back it's kind of perfect for me right
now
says it's time to set the outpost free
inflict as little damage as possible as
you make your way through to the rival
captain
if you can you should try to convince
the captain to give up the outpost and
join your cause
every step you take towards your end
goal will bring you
closer to a better world
here's the first line of defense
that's a bomb lover
back in the spot corrected
works that drain pipe
spin the twirly wheel and open that
drain
just a few moves left make them count
everything's clocking together
a key for every lock keep going
that cage is holding a helper
anyway we're going up to the
brontosaurus those bronze sources are
cool
uh yeah eventually i have to go through
all the gear and make sure
that like it's all sold or whatever
like i don't know do we have like
a maximum amount
[Music]
tim really again
thanks thanks buddy
how are you
they never lost hope you'd come but
weren't sure if they'd last long enough
to see it
says the tribe's been hard on them
return to the fort and rest or i need
you to fight
wants revenge on those who caged them
but trust you'll take care of it
i will
looks like an armory is that like a
a grenade launcher
what
oh my god
a sharpshooter the scaffolding looks
unstable
let us stay clear of the red ray here's
the second line of defense
danger
um
oh
oh
timber better big bump will bring it
down
switch off the light
there we go smack it to get a barrel out
of it
then hit it toward the gate and blast it
that looks slowly shoot it and watch it
blow
not too close though
you're in almost there
oh you know we're gonna have to to fight
with the general now it belongs to your
tribe now
oh that's it
as you made them weaker but they won't
give up
your sifu thanks you your tribe is
growing stronger
apple shops are open
[Music]
hmm
each weapon has its own tribal weapon if
you defeat the rival tribe you acquire
its weapon
by helping your own tribe you'll acquire
its weapon
you're now allied with a tribe you can
decide to switch your allegiance and
ally with a different tribe
go to the tribe fort and talk to the
shifu and change your allegiance
says you did a great job capturing the
outpost
figures the honor belongs to the tribe
too
he had a feeling you'd get along with
the myriad tribe
but it remained you seem to share the
same values as the myriad
of this conversation there's so much
story
that solving the tribe conflict won't
matter
unless you help make a stand
that doesn't sound good out of dates
forebodings are justified
the jumbo puff needs to be taken care of
he says the time has come to confront
the jumbo puff at the end
[Music]
strong enough to endure the
oxygen-deprived
dead zone okay
follow along
hmm
that might actually work pretty well uh
look fast travel there apparently now
boomerang
rifles regular gun
oh this is cool too
wielding your guns
saboteur
perks range basically
i don't know
your chance to pursue
your biological amounts
[Music]
[Music]
inventory is it this is bonds
we're gonna go that way but we can't get
out we have to run out this way
ran out the way we came oh really cool
already cultivating the area we ran
through
how the hell did they get these big ass
plants
already here it's not been even like
three hours like
what
that's the way we came because this is
the way out
or is it a full circle
i'm just being dumb dumb
hear all the shops
hmm
but cautions you not to be too eager if
you want to make a good deal
oh these are the add-ons and stuff
i want to sell things
if i like
now i'm like oh i don't want this 21.
but the question is if i sell things is
it better
than breaking things down
don't tell what's up dude
wasn't too bad a deal was it
how are you doing tim what is uh what
are you looking into today
see that's the thing like i need
the add-ons this are the handles
we need to get
might need to shave your eyes night's
over
this guy is
your arranged weapons says you'll get a
special price
suggests you take it easy you
same deal
uh tim what are you doing today huh
how's that your life been
you got over that
oh
flash the slash
i'm punching the hell out of them
oh
are you kidding me it's executioning
people
oh dance people get the hell out of here
dum-dums
the sun is high
that's a good note easy prey for looper
looping
for everyone else they're a perfect
mountain easily tamed if they are kept
fed
oh you can uh use them as bounces to
travel huh
it's the chug yard
okay
not a proper waypoint
the board mainly has posts from those
that used to work at the chug yard back
in
you're on the right track
it's in the area module for the gun
smackdown
you've had better days
leveling up gives you full health good
to know
so
take your time and enjoy the daylight
tribes always scavenging for scrap and
the yard has plenty to go around
but they should have stuck to looting
instead of playing around with sprockets
like are these guys hostile or
what's going on here are they
let's see
the sky's the limit now let's take this
back to earth
wow you really took that all the way
down to the end
in flames
only uh only me could figure this stuff
out huh
it's a wonder some of these up and downs
still work
yes they built machines better in the
past
these up and downs meaning
airplanes or elevators
i love you how he just knows how to do
everything
encountering it's nothing surprising
the spent nuclear fuel the toxinol
dumped in the surf had
detrimental effects on the marine
habitats while the overflowing landfills
contaminated the groundwater
combined this sent their world hurtling
on an inevitable
road to ruin
i need to brush up on my wando but i
have a feeling he believes it was you
that caused the batteries
oh and he says he knows you you used to
call him
gizmo
gizmo remembers you as a nice kitten and
he construed
typo but gizmo says how you experience a
memory can be different
you know he understands history made
looper loop
he says you should know that
gizmo found that flame
wait no bright i've got all the code do
you have to i don't have to
let's see what happens if we always go
positively the world is actually going
to
gizmo says it's taken a long time to
bring the past up to the
he can't leave the under yard as he has
now
you should return when you've retrieved
the scrap
there's no time to waste if you want to
make the mechton strong enough
the mech strong enough
the light of day shows how bad the world
has become
they're short of breath and death to
this zone
better take care he who
you're discovering hazard zones these
zones are vast areas covered in deadly
hazards
you can only withstand the hazard for so
long before it kills you so
airfall hazards become several time
types
bio-contaminated cryogenic incendiary
radioactive and
oxygen deprived dead zone
your gear and the resistance you chose
during character creation to determine
how long you can survive these hard
zones and how much damage you take from
the hazard weapons
at a resistance of a hundred of that
type of hazard use 100 percent of the
hazard
interesting
we had a feeling that was gonna happen
anyway
um
you seem better water moose
faster uh
cy power
light aura needed
light lauren
he's spark funny hello kinetics
oh that's usually
okay this is
the biogenetics
i don't know how much of that i'm
actually going to use
[Music]
i mean i could upgrade resistances
but it's not going to help here anyway
don't have much time
this is an oxygen deprived zone
see how that goes now all right
oh do we gotta hook a hard right there
to the cave
that's his cave the leftover you're
looking for
oh we can breathe fine in here
[Music]
control
that's nice
little lives here
damn it uh it looks like
you might actually have to do it the
right trigger
be careful down here easy to get trapped
look up knock down
empty parts
[Music]
okay that's cool sports brew
this is what i wanted
and now i saw yeah
he does that sometimes and then 20
minutes will be fine
yeah buy him
how did game night go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i don't know that was a
oh it's in the thing part those
gun weapons stuff
who helm
getting harder to see
oh my god get back
he says that's enough to get the mechdon
functional
you'll have an engine a fuel soaker a
gun
and a gathering net but no armor nor
enough oxygen supply
he made a suction device so the mechton
can use the black tar as an
instant refuel you can also use it to
clear oily goo
pugs so you can pass and access hard to
get to areas
but it needs ammunition and by that he
means the scripts
he says if they're trained right they'll
turn into a distraction for the jumbo
puff
speech the best way to find scripts is
to go talk to moog
he knows the ins and outs of every
breathing thing left alive after the
apocalypse
unfortunately this means you'll have to
venture farther out into the dead zone
than moog's camp on the steep depot once
you find moog
you'll be able to give you directions to
where you'll find scripts
so
he noticed the jumbo puff has a short
attention span
so the script should distract it long
enough for you to inflict some damage
all right upon it
didn't think it could be better
because
you that's fine
i will go though
looking boil the mk
cannot cross the oil pool but you can
use it to remove the oil
just get close to it
you're scared yet it's getting dark
the grease monkey's mech on is built
sturdy
just like himself can you imagine how
this place used to look
before the dead oil
might want to hold your breath before
you head any further
you're about to witness the breathtaking
vistas
of what's known as the dead zone
jump places
that over there is steep o deeper the
cliffside that moog
hangs onto
how do we dismount again
hold down oh
oh
uh sudden
[Music]
um
transport my weapon interacts
oh no
that's the trick to traveling
oh
don't slip
boys there we go
this one's impressed to see you out here
he figured you'd be dead by now
not many are as tough and clever as you
must be
to pull the trigger when the time comes
choosing what to kill and what to spare
are the most important decisions you'll
make
you might have a steady aim but you need
to be sure that you pick your
targets with care it's hard to make
those life or death decisions for others
but someone's got to do it otherwise
they'll do it themselves and you know
they'll miss
when it comes to monsters he mostly
picks who dies
says it's wild that the world seems to
be coming back
but he supposes that means more monsters
for him to shoot
a monkey wonders why you work so hard to
keep things alive
bullets help thin the herd instead says
you should give up on working with the
stubborn myriad
he keeps trying to put out their lights
and they keep putting up new ones
he's afraid you're just as stubborn as
them
but enough of that right he says the
wildlife
nature has changed and turned against us
instincts of survival took over when the
world changed
he's not sure about their veggie diet
anymore
and if it's changed who knows what it's
done with the chemical composition of
their body output
right now though he feels he's come to a
point
where he's got a pretty clear idea on
the whereabouts of monsters
says as big as they are the world is
bigger
to find where they are you need to see
it takes practice before you can call
yourself a monster hunter
fortunately for you he can help he
understands you need to start off with
something small before you go
big there's no
better place to start than a script cave
hunting
all right
let's see i really dislike that fast
track how they do first travel
subtle it is not
take you
interesting that we got to pull
this out
i had a feeling they had some loot in
here
i like how they have this stuff
[Music]
hmm
wait it's the strip hole up place is
just
filled with critters
boom
like i don't know if i should be doing
this like this or
i should be out of my costume
do you think you are
play time is over
the scrap keeps piling up
ultimate melee weapon ultimate ranged
weapon
thing
like rolling around here i'm like wow
all right let's see
well
nice and quick
this is like when i played assassin's
creed so much i got you so used to
making sure
i got everything around oh
idea go knock the lid off that sludge
truck
it'll fill the place up and you can get
up to that entrance there
have to love another fresh start
you're in things
oh it's a squirt
doesn't look like a happy [ __ ]
looks like the switches need to be
turned to match
so enough charge can flow through the
conduct just a few moves left
make them count
[Music]
as i click the wrong button good
that's enough electric current to
initiate the actuators and
activate the framework
extreme
[Music]
things
was a ranged weapon
okay
gonna go
up now
and hopefully find the melo up bailey
welcome
what is that
two-handed
weapon
okay
move it before you get your ticket
pop up
ah
anywho
in the old world roads like this really
led somewhere
now most of them are going back to kids
i love it how he uses it to fuel up the
machine
instead of just you know get rid of it
from something with it
that seems weird
what is there a reason why it's like
that
yeah we'll go back to
some four minutes left on stream raiders
the day is getting on
getting out the tin can
oh
he says that's enough scripts to sustain
the mekton's claw crane cannon with
infinite ammunition well done
not his cleanest invention so far but it
gets the job done
use it to suck up gooey oil puddles in
the mekton's way so
gizmo's made vehicles before to confront
the jumbo puff himself
but failed but this time it's different
my god
it's time to put a stop to the world
eater now otherwise he fears the damage
it's caused to the tree already will be
too much to handle
time to improve the mechdon before you
confront the puff
there are more wreck boxes out in the
dead zone with gear you should be able
to equip the mechdon with on your own
he got the idea to build the mechton
when he found a big crate containing the
metal frame
for something toxinol had named an
exoskeleton
gizmo wants to help if he can
says you should take it easy
all right
every day comes with a new chance to
save the world
all right
so it looks like we have we can travel
all the way from here through
and here is a village
what it looks like on the other
side
of this oil pool
hmm why don't we do this why don't we
get
here and then we'll call it
which is a faster way to move through
the world you know
you could just go to a place like this
to get a proper meal back in the old
not
shot
want to make sure you guys knew going
why can't i
the flute
all the big crates on the outside that's
what they were saying before it's always
in a big crate
wherever you wind up that's where you
belong
gotcha
we just happen to run into here
unknowingly
this is the cave we went to before
we have to engage them only because it's
xp
we don't know also if the xp is required
or not
because
injured
i wanted that
figured
vehicles would have something oh
keep getting handles for things but no
blades like we need a blade
be able to [ __ ] be able to make some
type of weapon here guys
not doing a good job in that aspect this
is more like it
there's a place and time for everything
but
for that city scenario it's already
coming
oh my god no no no
this is not a good idea for us here
nothing beats your own two feet
i understand what they're saying for
put one robot foot in front of the other
who could stop you now
there was uh leave that scrap behind
remember any wreck you can crawl away
from is a good one
this one
bio blop container
or the bio block
in this building
to be up here
look over here
oh that's over here
sure you know how to motivate this
enough of that
probably not the correct way to do it
but i
these steel legs
let me go this way
a sharp bang shelter 7b
is still there open and ready to shelter
nice shot
all right
[Music]
you